face aux des boues des manifestants
morts dans les affrontements sanglants
de samedi entre forces de l'ordre et
opposants au président l'imam est leader
de l'opposition margot dicko dirige la
prière des funérailles les militants
appellent à la démission du président
malien ibrahim boubacar keïta c'est
autour de cette mosquée que se sont
déroulés les affrontements les plus
sanglants du week end
le lieu de culte ou prêche l'imam a été
transformée en camp retranché
par crainte de voir les forces de
sécurité venir arrêter le chef de file
de la contestation malienne alors que
vendredi le mouvement est entré selon
ses mots en désobéissance civile l'imam
a appelé ses partisans au calme
nos combats comme en maintenant ce
progrès stores et la nation malienne
c'est pour là encore donner à cette
nation sa dignité sa monnaie c'est pour
faire en sorte que cette avance
catastrophe eu à mener fallu dans cette
citation ou le mal est en train de
s'abîmer foule vieux ne soit pas une
réalité que ça soit un genou ce
mouvement que nous avons une tranchée de
pense réellement ce le début d'un espoir
qu'il doit rester et vouloir se profile
mais dans la visite et le doute dans ce
pays à 95% musulman
mahmoud dicko est une figure familière
pour les maliens cet allié du président
ib cas est aujourd'hui l'un de ses plus
fervents opposants
il incarne un courant rigoriste de
l'islam et a su jouer un rôle clef dans
la crise sécuritaires au mali
en parvenant à s'imposer comme médiateur
avec les mouvements jihadistes qui
sévissent dans le nord aujourd'hui
mahmoud dicko a rassemblé partis
politiques et organisations de la
société civile dans un mouvement dit du
5 juin au mouvement m 5
ses partisans réclament une alternance à
la présidence ils jugent ib car
responsable de l'effondrement de la
croissance économique de la dégradation
sécuritaire doublé de l'incapacité d'y
faire face ainsi que de la défaillance
de l'état
il a refusé de se détacher de son
premier ministre de dissoudre
l'assemblée
et voilà que des fils du pays sont morts
l'assemblée a été brûlée et tous les
dégâts qui ont été causés
il en est le seul responsable s'il avait
écouté les gens on n'en serait pas là
les réformes attendues du mali sotelma
complexe est tellement profonde qu'on
paye jamais les résoudre on ne peut
jamais faire ces réformes dans un pays
divisé alors qu'ibrahim boubacar keita a
annoncé la dissolution de la cour
constitutionnelle le président malien
peine à faire revenir le calme
un gouvernement d'union nationale est
une piste espérer dans le pays avec la
possibilité que des personnes issues du
mouvement m 5 soit associé à la
reconstruction du pays